-We're here with our frien
Henry Winkler.
Is this a true story?
We were talking about
your grandson
dressing up like The Fonz --
that the leather jacket
was not originally
going to be part
of the iconic costume?
-No, I --
I had to wear a golf jacket.
It was a McGregor golf jacket.
It was puce, and I --
-[ Laughs ]
-You know,
I've said this before,
but it's very hard
to be cool in puce.
-Yes.
-I just want to say.
And the collar
would not stay up,
because ABC thought I was goin
to be associated with crime.
-Right. This is the times
we're living in,
that leather meant crime.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Leather
and a T-shirt together...
-Yeah, that's a crime spree.
-And then, I had on
engineer boots that I wore
in "The Lords of Flatbush,
'cause I like to bring
something from
one project to another.
Then, Gary Marshall went to AB
and said, "You know, The Fon
could be hurt
if he was in a cycle accident.
And they said,
"If you do a scene
with his bike,
he can wear leather."
-And that was it?
-And that was it.
Then slowly but --
That's why you see me wheeling
the bike in to Arnold's.
That it is in the living roo
of the Cunninghams,
in my apartment
above the garage.
-I see. So you just had
to have the bike everywhere.
-Yes, I had
And then, eventually,
they let that go,
and I was very fortunate,
years later,
to give the jacket
to the Smithsonian.
-A very -- If anything deserve
to be there, it's that.
Now, Henry, we've talked about
that you like trout fishing,
and based on these photos,
I can't tell...
I can't tell if you really do.
Do you really?
Do you really like
trout fishing?
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I want to tell you.
I would love --
See, you know what that is
That is a cutthroat
and a rainbow.
They mated, and that is
a hybrid right there.
-That's a hybrid?
-Isn't that beautiful?
-It's beautiful.
-That is a beautiful fish.
And then, I give it a kiss
I take a picture,
and give it back.
-Oh, so you don't
eat your trout?
-I've never -- I won't eve
eat a trout in a restaurant.
-Really? Even when it's
too late for the trout?
-I think -- You know what?
I think they're so majestic,
and if I --
I love trout fishing,
but if I could, I wish --
You know, when they --
when you show them all playing
their instruments before,
you know, at home, the band?
-Yeah.
-I wish I could sing.
-What would you sing?
-I would sing --
Well, I would sing
a combination.
The Boss, Bruno Mars, Ben Platt,
Sia, and Brandi Carlile.
[ Laughter ]
-I cannot believe how much
thought you put into that.
-No, I -- just they are
on my mind and on my iPod.
-I mean, five winners --
five winners in a row.
-Oh, my God.
They're so good.
-Hey, last time you were here,
you had just finished shooting
the Wes Anderson film
that just premiered at Cannes,
"The French Dispatch."
I'm so excited to see it.
I always look forward
to his films.
It must have been thrillin
to do.
-You learn the language of Wes
You really do.
He is very specific.
Bob Balaban
was my brother in it.
We're brothers together.
I can't even
show you a picture yet.
But I whispered to Bob, I said
"I have an idea.
Should I ask Wes?"
And he said
out of the side of his mouth
"No," and so I didn't.
[ Laughter ]
And then, Benicio del Toro
was in our set,
and we went to dinner together
They are just
lovely human beings.
And Tilda Swinton,
who is, like, this icon
of independence in the world
Just wonderful.
-Oh, that is so lovely to hear
Now, I want to finish tonight --
We used to have a traditio
back in the days
when we were all here.
It's called "$5 Friday."
You remember.
I don't need to tell you.
-I do. I do.
-And you were here on a da
we did it,
and you put your $5 in, and we
still have it right here.
I'd like to show you.
This is the Henry Winkler $5
And what happens is,
we spin this around,
and we take out the winner
and they get the money.
Now, when you were here,
Henry, you won.
You're -- it's the first tim
a guest had ever won,
and I'll let you
tell everybody what you did.
-Well, I was in a limousine,
and I was on my way
to do "Actor's Studio."
"Inside the Actor's Studio."
I was never invited,
and so finally I was invited
to do an interview
with Alec Baldwin.
Got the call, "You won,"
and I asked how much it was.
And I think it was $190.
-Yeah.
-It was such a hard decision..
[ Laughter ]
...not to take the money,
but I decided, "You know what?
Traffic in New York, and I -
Monday -- This was a Friday.
Monday, treat the crew
to whatever they wanted.
-Right.
-And I think you had pizza
-We had pizza.
We always respect
that you gave yourself
the weekend to think it over
[ Laughter ]
All right.
So here we go.
It's $5 Friday again.
We want to see if Henry Winkle
has the luck he deserves
for being the nicest man
in show business.
But this time
the winner is Arbulu.
Christine is the winner.
And knowing Christine,
there will be no pizza...
[ Laughter ]
...but we do look forward
to her new clothes on Monday
Thank you so much, Henry.
"Monsters at Work" is currentl
streaming on Disney+.